سفينه عبريه اخرى تختطف في اليمن وتل ابيب
تكشف حمولتها خيبه امل امريكيه خلال
الهدنه الالاف يملؤون شوارع العواصم
الاوروبيه دعما للقطاع بعد المرحله
الثالثه في القطاع لا هدنه في الضفا
النتنياهو يضع ثلاثه اهداف للحرب فيما
تقبل الفصائل بتمديد الهدنه مجددا دعم
جديد من سويسرا المحايده للاوكرانيين
واقوى دبابات روسيا تختفي امام الدارت
الاوكرانيه بين بولندا واوكرانيا ما الذي
يجري زعيم فرنسي يتعين على الغرب ترك
الناتو واتباع الجانب الروسي وفنلندا تغلق
كافه المعابر الحدوديه مع روسيا اليمن
يواصل
التدخل الدول تزيد من ضغطها على الدوله
العبريه ومن اليمن يزداد هذا الضغط فقد
اكد مسؤول دفاعي امريكي لوكاله اوس بريس
ان مسلحين مجهولين استولوا على ناقله
النفط سنترال بارك المملوكه لشركه زودياك
ماريتايم المرتبطه بتلابيب في خليج عدن
البعيد نسبيا عن المناطق التي يسيطر عليها
الحوثيين بحسب الصحيفه ياتي ذلك فيما تكرر
اعلان تل ابيب عن التصدي لهجمات بالصواريخ
والمسيرات فوق البحر الاحمر قادمه من
اليمن فيما افادت صحيفه عبريه بان السفينه
كانت تحمل شحنه من حمض الفوسفوريك ق قبل
ذلك اعلن مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق
الشؤون الانسانيه دخول عدد قياسي من
شاحنات المساعدات الى القطاع للمره الاولى
منذ اندلاع الحرب في السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي حيث تم ايصال 61 شاحنه محمله
بالمساعدات الانسانيه الى شمال القطاع كما
تم ارسال 200 شاحنه اخرى من معبر نيتسان
العبري ووصلت
17 منها الى القطاع فيما قالت وزيره
الدوله للتعاون الدولي في الخارجيه القطر
لولو الخاطر ان قطر مستعده لارسال اي
كميات مطلوبه من المساعدات هذا وكانت
تلبيب والفصائل قد نفذت المرحله الثالثه
من تبادل الاسرى والمحتجزين واكدت الفصائل
تسليم 13 محتجزا عبريا وثلاث محتجزين
تايلنديين
ومحتجزة شبكه ان بي سي نيوز ان اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن تشعر بخيبه امل
لعدم افراج الفصائل عن اسرى امريكيين في
اليوم الثاني من صفقه التبادل مع تل ابيب
والتي شهدت مشكلات عده ادت الى تاخير
العمليه هنا وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد
اوستون يطالب نظيره العبري اف جلاند خلال
اتصال هاتفي بانشاء مناطق امنه في القطاع
لتسهيل الوصول الى المساعدات الانسانيه
بينما جدد الجيش العبري دعوته لسكان قطاع
غزه للانتقال من الشمال نحو الجنوب حيث
تتوفر المساعدات الانسانيه باعتبار ان
شمال القطاع منطقه حرب خطيره اضاف الجيش
في بيانه عبر منصه اكس لا تحاول الانتقال
الى شمال القطاع وممنوع الدخول الى البحر
او الاقتراب لمسافه كيلومتر من الحدود
العبريه اما وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ونقلا
عن مصدر مقرب من الفصائل فقد اكدت بان
الفصائل وافقت على تمديد الهدنه الانسانيه
في القطاع من يومين الى اربعه ايام اخرى
ليبدي النتنياهو ترحيبه باحتمال اطلاق
سراح عشره رهائن مقابل كل يوم هدنه اضافي
بحسب رايترز فيما قام النتنياهو بجوله
تفقديه داخل القطاع مشيرا الى ان هناك
ثلاثه اهداف لهذه الحرب هي القضاء على
الفصائل واعاده جميع المخطوفين وضمان ان
القطاع لن يشكل تهديدا لتل ابيب مره اخرى
مع تواصل الهدنه فلا هدنه في الضفه حيث
قتل ثمانيه فلسطينيين برصاص القوات
العبريه خلال 24 ساعه في الضفه الغربيه
هذا واعتقلت القوات العبريه خلال يوم
ليرتفع عدد المعتقلين منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الى
3200 من جانب اخر افادت صحيفه واينت
العبريه بان الجيش العبري صدر ما يقرب من
5 ملايين شيكل من القطاع منذ بدايه الحرب
ليخرج الاف المتظاهرين في العاصمه
الالمانيه برلين والعاصمه البريطانيه لندن
ضد الحرب على القطاع وانتقد المتظاهرون
حكوماتهم بسبب دعمها لتل ابيب بالمال
والاسلحه لننتقل الى سوريا حيث افادت
وسائل اعلام بسماع ذوي صوت انفجار ضخم في
العاصمه السوريه دمشق في محيط منطقتي
المزه والمعظم لتعلن صحيفه الوطن السوريه
ان هجوما اسرائيليا استهدف مطار دمشق
الدولي ادى لخروجه عن الخدمه
كسر
الحياد دوله الحياد التي لا تتدخل في
الحروب تتحرك نعم هنا اعلن الرئيس
السويسري الان برسيه ان بلاده ستقدم
لاوكرانيا مساعدات تزيد قيمتها عن 100
مليون يورو وسيتم استخدام الاموال في
عمليه ازاله الالغام وتوفير الغذاء كما
سيسهل تصدير الحبوب من اوكرانيا فيما
افادت صحيفه فوربس بان المساعدات العسكريه
الغربيه المقدمه لقوات كيام ليس لها معنا
بسبب الافتقار الى القياده العسكريه
المختصه والمنسق في اوكرانيا مضيفا انه
وبالاضافه الى ذلك لا تمتلك القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه العدد المطلوب من
معدات كشف الالغام وخبراء المتفجرات
المدربين تدريبا جيدا ليصرح زعيم حزب
الوطنيين الفرنسيين فلوريان فليبو بانه
يتعين على الغرب التوقف عن اتباع خطى
النيتو والبدء في استعاده العلاقات مع
روسيا واشار الى ان الولايات المتحده حده
والمانيا تريدان العوده الى الاسواق
الروسيه في اقرب وقت ممكن من جانب اخر قال
مستشار البنتاجون السابق العقيد دوجلاس
مكريجر ان القوات الروسيه قادره على
الوصول الى الحدود مع بولندا لكن ذلك ليس
ضمن تطلعاتها لان الروس لا يريدون غرب
اوكرانيا هنا افاد اوليغ سوسك المستشار
السابق للرئيس الاوكراني الاسبق ليوند
كوتشما بان العلاقات غير المستقره بين
بولندا واوكرانيا تؤدي الى صراع عسكري
مفتوح مشددا على ان زيلينسكي لا يدرك
الخطر الكامل للوضع الحالي وبالتالي فهو
لا يحاول حتى اتخاذ خطوات لتخفيف الحدود
بعيدا عن اوكرانيا قال رئيس الوزراء
الفنلندي بيتري اوربولاق مستعده لاغلاق
اخر لنقطه تفتيش لا تزال تعمل على الحدود
مع روسيا اذا استمر تدفق اللاجئين وبذلك
تغلق كافه المعابر الحدوديه مع روسيا
وبعوده الى الميدان الاوكراني حس دبابه تي
90 ام الروسيه التي تشارك في العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه على دروع تمويه خاصه
قادره على اخفائها عن اجهزه التصوير
الحراري والرادارات كما ان عمليه رصد
الدبابات من قبل الدرونات وطائرات
الاستطلاع ستصبح اصعب
[موسيقى]
ايضا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ا